in a world where clocks about we
constantly ask what time is it but
rarely do we stop to consider what is
time in the July 25th science news our
staff writers tackle this question they
take a look at time from three
completely different perspectives body
brain and universe when it comes to the
body's clock biologists ponder time from
the perspective of evolutionary history
they want to know how and why life-forms
acquired internal clocks that guide
everyday life molecular biology writer
Tina Hoffman say explores the circadian
clocks built into nearly every one of
ourselves and how they relate to the
most primitive clocks found in archaea
and out our brains take on time is a
separate story neuroscience writer Laura
Sanders explores how the clocks in our
heads help us make sense of the world
and what makes our perception of time
appear to change as a consequence of our
experiences there are even some hints
about how faulty timekeeping in the
brain can factor in to disorders such as
schizophrenia perhaps the most brain
boggling exploration of time comes from
physics writer Andrew Grant he grapples
with time in terms of grab and the
grandeur of the universe
why does time always run forward even
though the laws of physics should permit
it to tick backward a new simulation
points to gravity and suggests that the
force may allow the universe to have one
past the Big Bang and two futures you
can read about these explorations of
time and more wlwt's org slash
you